There is a big myth in communication and
the myth is this. There is a perfect
time. There is a right time to say
something. Let me tell you that that is
a harmful
mindset. There will never be the perfect
time to have the conversation. Now,
don't get me wrong, there are times that
are better than others to bring
something up, but there's never a
perfect time. I want to number one
highlight this this fact that I have
lived through in my life is that if you
wait you get sick.
And I why do I say sick? It's it's what
we teach our kids. Sierra and I have I
have two kids. We have two kids, eight
and six. And our kids have done this
thing now especially with brushing their
teeth where they'll just lie. Like I
know he didn't brush his teeth because
I'm like right behind him. I can see he
can't see me in the door and he'll just
run it underwater
and then act like he brushed his teeth.
Anybody else do that? And admittedly, I
for sure did that. But we're having to
do this thing where it's we're teaching
them that if you hold in lies either by
a lie or hold something in by omission,
lies make you sick.
because I believe that it's true. If you
have a lie in your life right now that
you're living, just hearing my voice say
that, it's going to turn you into nods
and it's going to come right up to mind.
That that's out of that's you out of
alignment with yourself. And so, it's
calling attention to that. And that
might be uncomfortable, but lies make
you sick. And part of that, how does
that relate to when you have a
conversation?
It's the fact that when you stop saying
what you need to say now and say, "I'm
just going to wait." Uh, you know what?
I could talk to them, but I I just I'm
waiting for the right time. I'm I'm
waiting for that perfect time. That
train is never coming. There is not a
right time. There is only now and not
now.
If you wait to say what you need to say
to somebody to have the conversation,
pain comes, more problems come. All
right? I know they say more money, more
problems. Um, more time, more problems.
Most, at least that's what I've lived
out. Let me give you some examples. All
right? If you wait to tell a truth, the
lie only gets bigger. The lie only gets
more harmful. When it comes to telling
the truth, you need to say it now. It
would have been best if you said it in
the past, but the next best time is now
before it gets worse. If you waited to
tell that person in your relationship
that I'm not really feeling it, I'm not
this isn't for me, but you're afraid to
hurt their feelings and so you just live
a a lie of that you're not really into
them. You're not really in you're not
invested in this. Or maybe it's a
friendship that like you're you're just
being pleasant, but you know, it's not
really doing anything for you. It's not
growing you. It's not something you're
invested in. If you wait
to tell that employee that you need to
let them go, if you wait to fire
somebody, what happens? It ends up being
a year later and now the problems have
only compounded. Now you have more
problems. Why? Because you decided that
that anxiety, that gh, that feeling,
that pit in your stomach where you get
nervous. Everybody gets it, by the way.
I get it, too. It's It's overcoming that
hump.
You decided that the consequence of
saying nothing is
worth less than the anxiety of what
you're feeling right now. So, you would
choose to avoid the discomfort of now.
But let me tell you, the discomfort of
now only grows into the pains of
tomorrow, the pains of later. So, here's
a takeaway. There's a conversation that
you need to have right now if you're
still listening to me. So, what is that
conversation? I want you to think about
it in your mind. There's a conversation
that you're needing to have and you're
choosing not to have it because you're
waiting for the right time.
It's not coming. I'm going to say it
again and again in this episode. It's
not coming. You need to grab your phone
today and call them or write the email
or have the meeting. You need to do it
because the longer you put it off, the
worse things are going to get. Listen to
me. It has never been true that the
longer you wait to say it, to have the
conversation, the better things get. It
didn't work that way. It only gets
worse. What happens when you finally
have that conversation? They go, "Why
didn't you tell me a year before?" Well,
I I just couldn't. This is making me
think of how you can tell a parent.
Makes me think of Aladdin. You know,
when it was like Aladdin had the chance
to tell Jasmine that he wasn't really a
prince, but he just he just really
couldn't do. It's it's that if you I
can't believe I just brought Aladdin
into my episode. What am I doing?
If you wait, things only get worse.
That's that's the takeaway. So, what do
we do with that? This conversation
you're thinking about that you know you
need to have. There's some exceptions to
this that I want to highlight. When is
it not okay to talk or say the thing
right now? Number one, when your
physical safety is at risk.
Emotional abuse, physical abuse are at
risk when you're in an environment that
you could actually be harmed if you say
something. In that case, yes, wait or
don't say it at all. I would much rather
you place a security over your emotions
in your life versus causing some kind of
abuse or trauma or harm. Number two, if
your nervous system isn't prepared for
the conversation, I'm not talking about
nerves like you just I'm I'm I'm
jittery. I I have a pit in my stomach.
I'm not I'm not talking about that. I'm
talking about you feel so offc center
that you're going to get it wrong.
Meaning, I am starting at an 11. I am uh
all of my emotions have overridden
everything in my mind and I'm not going
to be able to function. it it's all
going to come out wrong because you are
not regulated in your mind. Again,
that's very different from just having
butterflies and feeling nervous about
it. And number three, when you are not
prepared
for the conversation in terms of a goal
of where you want to go, what do you
want to say? If you want to know when to
have that conversation you're waiting to
have instead of waiting for that perfect
time, here's what I want you to do.
Apply this framework. Number one, does
it need to be said? Number two, does it
need to be said now? And number three,
does it need to be said by me?
So many times I have things in my head
that I want to say to somebody. Maybe
it's a stranger. Maybe it's somebody at
a restaurant that you don't really know,
but somebody has to say something. I
have this filter of does is does it
really me that has to say this? Does it
need to be said right now? Because
there's so many times that I
there's a big weight lifted off me when
I think yes, somebody needs to hear
this, but they don't need to hear it
from me. They'll they will life will
teach him. Life will tell it to them.
Life will give them that lesson. And it
does not to be it does not need to be
told by me. I'm not going to be the one
to sway them. That's that's not going to
do it. It might feel good, but it's this
other filter I apply. And that is, am I
saying it because it needs to be said or
am I just saying it to be heard? Am I
just saying it to feel better? In other
words, is it really going to move the
conversation or am I just saying it to
fan my own flames to make it feel good
for myself? Is this an ego thing? Do I
really have to say it? Was it helpful?
Did I say it to be helpful or did I say
it to be hurtful? Those are filters that
are going to help you. So when you apply
that framework, does it need to be said?
Does it need to be said now? And does it
need to be said by me? That's going to
help you understand in those moments, is
now a better time to have the
conversation. Again, there's no right
time, but there's certainly a better
time more than others. Timing is also
incredibly important. Like think about
how much time influences a conversation.
I want you to think in your mind of a
conversation that was very difficult
here lately and ask yourself the
question was the timing of it any factor
had I chosen a better moment even 5
minutes before maybe 5 minutes after
something would have changed the dynamic
timing is important for example if when
the kids get home if I were to have a
conversation with Sierra right then and
there a very important conversation when
where I I'm I'm getting stuff ready for
dinner. The kids are upstairs or
downstairs and doing their homework and
things are going crazy and chaotic. Is
that the right time? Probably not. I'm
not saying I can't say, "Hey, I got
something important. I want to make sure
we we talk about it and kind of put a
pin in it to to to bookmark it." But
there's also a time and place to have
these kind of conversations. Again, it's
doesn't mean it's perfect. That doesn't
mean there's right, but I would
certainly say there are time frames that
are more suited than others rather than
just pushing your own time frame on it.
So, we also want to be considerate of
the other person's time frame. Now, here
is the golden rule. Number three, I want
to give you a golden framework that has
helped me a golden rule and it's this.
Wait 24 hours.
If you're not sure whether you should
say something or not, if you should
respond to that email, to that comment,
to that conversation that somebody had,
wait 24 hours. If it's still bothering
you the next day, then that is your gut.
That is your natural system saying, "I
need to have a response to this." One
time I got an email from an opposing
attorney
and it was the snarkiest thing I've ever
read.
You ever had those kind of people who
feel like everything that they do is
just made of gold? Like he he had a case
and we were against each other and he
just thought his client's case was the
best case and I I didn't agree. There
was some law that plainly said he was he
was wrong, but he thought there was some
way he could get creative about it.
Anyway, so he sent me an email that was
just snarky of all the ways I was wrong
and how I was going to lose.
Well, what did I do, man? I went right
to that keyboard. I I started writing an
email right back to him and I was just I
was Beethoven. I I was just masterful
drafting this email that was going to
zing him. It was just gonna upper
cut punch him in the jaw.
And what I decided to do thankfully
thankfully is right before I pressed
send I said, "You know what? I'm just
going to wait. I got my 24 hours. I'm
going to wait."
That next morning, I didn't even wait 24
hours before looking at it again. I I
the next morning I looked at it and I
almost laughed at what I was writing. I
mean, my my email, I almost laughed at
it of like, why did I think this was
going to do anything? That's not going
to change his mind. You know, I don't
need any of this. And I deleted it. I
deleted it. Instead, I waited a few days
later and I just replied to his email
and said, "Thank you." That was it. All
right. Wait 24 hours. If you're not sure
when to say it, that 24 hours is a
pretty good rule. Maybe it's something
that's weighing on me that I want to
tell a friend. Maybe I have that thought
right in that moment and if I don't feel
comfortable about it, I wait 24 hours.
Let me see if it's still bothering me.
Then if it's still bothering me, then
it's going to bother me for one or two
more years. I fall into this habit of
feeling like
once I get over this hump of the busy of
life, then things smooth out. But the
older I've gotten, the more I've
realized this is life. I mean, this is
it's not going to stop. this is what it
is. I have to find joy in the now. I
have to I have to find joy in the chaos
and the busy. And sometimes I might feel
like I need to say something to somebody
and I go I'll just let me wait until
this happens and I I need I know I need
to have this heartto-he heart with my
mom.
And truthfully, y'all, that's what
happened to me. I needed to have a big
conversation with my mom. And maybe
you've needed to have one of those with
a family member. And I needed to have
one with my mom and talk about some big
things, some life things and things that
we should have talking about a long time
ago. And
I put it off. I pushed it because I
waited for the right moment. Thankfully,
I've been able to to have that
conversation with her and talk with her,
but it took me a long time.
I found excuses
to be busy. I found excuses to say I was
busy. Same for her.
And you know, I I wouldn't say it's
either. There's no fault I'm trying to
attribute whatsoever. If anything, I'll
take the the the blame or fault.
But I I hope you can resonate with that
that sentiment of where I know I need to
have this big conversation, but I
continue to say, "Well, I'll do it once
things slow down. I'll do it once the
kids schedule is easier. I'll do it
after I get back from this." And you
know what I do? You know what I did? I
just replaced whatever the rock was with
a different rock.
That's all I did.
And that pushed a conversation that
should have happened in the now to eight
months later. And within those eight
months, things just got layered. Things
got harder. It's it's like you have
something and you put it on a shelf and
you need to talk about it now, but dust
covers it and you don't use it and
things happen and things get stacked on
top of it and all of a sudden you can't
find it because it's on top of
everything else and you forgot your
thought. You forgot that you I really
wanted to reach out. I really wanted to
make this point. So, I want to put this
in a takeaway. Number one, if you're
waiting for the right moment to have the
conversation,
there is no right moment. It's not
coming. There is no perfect time.
There's only now and not now. There are
times and exceptions to when you need to
have a conversation.
One is your physical safety, emotional
safety. Two, if you're not regulated to
have that conversation where you're
going to be able to not only say what
you need to say, but hear [snorts] it in
a filter that is going to continue to
keep yourself regulated. Three, [snorts]
if you are not prepared for the
conversation in terms of logic, in other
words, you don't know what you want to
say, you're you're trying to spitball
and figure out what you want to say as
you're saying it. You you get to where
the other person is just going to get
frustrated and they go, "What do you
what do you want?" And you go, "Well, I
mean I mean, you know, I say all that to
say if you don't know where you're
going, they're going to get frustrated."
Those are scenarios where I would say
it's okay to find a better time. There's
a difference between the right time and
a better time. I agree that there's
better times to say things. There's
worse times to say things, but there's
no perfect time. I Let me be the example
of I know the pain of not saying what
you need to say when you should have
said it. not telling the truth when you
should have said it then and just
waiting because you chose and when I
chose to avoid the discomfort of the now
at the expense of the pain of the later
and that has been something that I
continue to work on and and I'm I'm here
with you if this resonates with you at
all and if you're thinking of that
conversation that you haven't had and
it's kind of churning right now in you
let me be the first to say, "Look, you
can do it. You really can. You're going
to live. You're going to live. You're
going to get after this conversation,
and there's going to be there's going to
be a before. There's going to be a life
before and a life after." And bottom
line is there's still going to be life.
And I bet you it's even better than you
thought it could ever be on the other
side. And either way, I'm going to be
right here supporting you, talking to
you, teaching all the way along. So many
times I have people that are reaching
out to me and saying, "Hey, I am
preparing for this conversation that I
have at work, at the office, I have this
interview, I need to fire an employee, I
need to try and ask for a raise. I have
to have this hard conversation with my
spouse or my child or or whatever it
is." And every time, deep down, it's a
plea for help of knowing I am afraid.
That's that's what I hear. It's it's
fear. It's fear from everyone saying I
I'm nervous about this. News flash, I
get nervous about conversations, too. If
you're not getting nervous, let me just
put that disclaimer out there. If you're
not feeling nervous about a
conversation, then you don't care about
the conversation. So, I want you to
understand that when you feel nervous
and you're going, "Why do I why I have
this pit in my stomach?" Take that as
joy. Count it as joy that you actually
care about what you're going to say. You
care about the person. You care about
that conversation. If you didn't care,
you wouldn't really worry at all about
your words. You wouldn't worry about
their interaction or the reaction from
them. So understand when you have that
nervous pit in your in your stomach
there, we're going to use that as good.
All right? We're going to use that as
good. And we're going to talk about that
in this episode. So, how do you best
prepare for this conversation? And I say
this conversation because I'm talking to
you. We're talking about the very
conversation you know that you need to
be having that is weighing on you, that
you are avoiding, that every time you
think about it, it keeps you up at
night. It you you lose track of what
you're doing. All of a sudden, your your
thoughts go out of focus because you're
so worried about this conversation. This
is the conversation we're going to be
talking about. Here's how I want you to
start preparing for it. You ready?
Number one, name your goal before your
emotions do. Set your goal for what you
want the conversation to be and how you
want it to turn out before your emotions
do. If you go into a conversation and
you don't have a goal, you are losing.
And I don't say that in terms of a
win-loss type of situation. I'm saying
you are setting yourself up for failure
if you don't have a goal. That is like
me saying, "Hey, you want to jump in the
car with me real quick?" And you go,
"Okay, where are we going?" I'm like, "I
have no clue. No idea, but I'm going to
spend 45 minutes of us just kind of
wandering around until I decide where I
might want to park." You go, "You're
you're crazy. If I if I want to go on a
flight." And you said, "Where you
going?" I go, "I don't you know what? I
don't really know. It wouldn't make
sense. You need to have a destination.
You have to have a destination for what
is the end result. So, you start
backwards. How do you prepare for a
difficult stressful conversation? You
start at the very end of it. All right?
You start at the very end. What do I
want them to know? So, if you have if
you can right now, I want you to get a
piece of paper out, maybe a a word
document, a Google document, whatever it
is, and I want you to write down goal
and then put a colon. What is my goal
for this conversation? If you don't know
the goal, you're lost. You're lost
because the other person is going to be
looking to you of where are we going?
Where what is what do you want? Ever had
anybody say, "What's your point? Where
are you going with this?
That's exactly what it is. Because
you're not telling them, you're not
informing them of your destination. And
that leaves both of you absolutely
clueless. When you write down your goal,
meaning I want them to hear me. I want
them to understand me. I want them to do
this or I need to feel this.
It's going to help clarify what your
standard is. If your goal is for them to
change their mind, that's going to be
very difficult. If your goal is for them
to apologize to you, n that's probably
the wrong goal. It is has to be some the
goal has to be something that you can
control. You can't control if they're
going to apologize or say that you're
right or that everything they believe in
is wrong. You have to set a goal that
you can control. That has to do with you
understanding what's happening. You
feeling more like you have a better
solid footing in the conversation. You
getting to say the thing that you've
always wanted to say. You see, these are
words that are coming from you, not what
you're expecting them to say. Having a
goal is so critical. It sounds basic.
It is basic. It is extremely difficult
to have the right goal. What happens a
lot of the time is
you have something in your head about
how the conversation should go and then
you get into the conversation and you
realize, wait, this isn't happening.
Have you ever been into a conversation
and you realize, well, wait, no, no, no.
This isn't how it's supposed to happen.
That you're you were I was going to say
this and then you were supposed to
apologize because that's that's how I
rehearsed it in my head. This is where
you say how wrong you are. How how you
finally are seeing the light. That's
never going to happen. If it does,
congratulations. Go get a lottery ticket
because that's going to be extremely
rare. Conversations rarely go how they
go in your head. That's just not the way
the world works. So, you need to write
down your goal. What do you want from
them? What do you want for you?
Basic goal. A very basic goal. Maybe
it's I want to feel heard on this issue.
I need to understand where they're
coming from. I need to let them go from
the company. I need to inform them that
this is their last day. Whatever it is,
you need to have a goal and make that
the bright line header of your true
north. Without it, you might as well not
have the conversation at all. You with
me? Number two, put the emphasis on
regulating your body more than
rehearsing your words. In fact, I would
go on to tell you that rehearsing your
lines
is damaging. Let me tell you why. I see
so many times in the legal field, and
there's a lot of attorneys, trial
attorneys who might be listening right
now nodding their head. Good attorneys
don't stick to line by line questions.
They keep it flexible.
So, what does that look like? Let's say
I have a pen and paper. All right.
Rather than writing and scripting out
every single one of my questions that I
want to ask a witness, instead I'm going
to put it in bullet points. I'm might
the first bullet point might be the
store. It might be um the money
exchange. It might be
um the trip. Like things that are
signpost to me that allow me to ask
questions and be flexible. Because let
me tell you the downside of rehearsing
and knowing my questions ahead of time
is that I might read a question and wait
for the answer
except I typically don't wait for the
answer. I'm starting to look at the next
question and I'm worried about what I'm
going to ask more than I'm actually
listening. So you know a new attorney a
green attorney from a more veteran by if
they're going and did you arrive at the
school that day and they're not even
really listening to the answer. Somebody
could be giving a very good answer
that's giving them lots of information,
but they're not listening because
they're just focused on the next
question. So, you miss things. That's
the point. You miss things. If you are
rehearsing your lines, you're going to
miss things because you're more focused
on you performing well, of you doing
well. Oh, no, no, that's not how I
wanted to say it. People who teach
public speaking,
if you rehearse your talk, you're going
to be much more concerned about the
exact wording and putting your placement
and making almost so manufactured that
it doesn't feel genuine and it doesn't
feel real and the other person's not
going to feel it versus you just know
generally where the message needs to be.
You know your goal, you know your
purpose and why you're there. and that
you're going to trust everything's going
to flow out of that and that's where you
feel the connection from people. So, put
the emphasis on regulating your body.
Then we can worry about is is there a
certain type of phrase that you want to
make sure and use because if you don't
have your body controlled, if you are
not
using your breath [snorts]
and you are not lowering your shoulders
and you are making sure your jaw is not
is your jaw tight right now? Are do you
have tightness in your ears and in your
cheeks and your forehead? And
what about your shoulders and your
hands? Are they they tense?
Is your is your core tight? Are are you
your shoulders drooped over? What's your
body position like? So, you have to make
sure you take temperature of that. If
you don't have your body controlled,
good luck trying to focus everything
else because your body's tied to those
emotions. And if you're not breathing,
it doesn't matter what kind of technique
I could teach you, what words I could
give you. None of it's going to work
because it's going to come out in a way
that you don't want. It's going to come
out defensive because your body is
feeling defensive because your body is
feeling flooded in that moment. So
control what you can control. How do I
want you to prepare for this hard
conversation? Regulate your body. Put
the focus on that. Preparing for this
conversation, I want you to think in
your mind. Think in your mind. What are
Imagine the conversation happening in
real time? The person sitting across
from you. You're you're at the you're in
the environment that you're going to
have the conversation with. How does
that feel? How does that feel to you?
What emotions are coming up? Prepare for
them now. Prepare for them now. So,
underneath wherever you're writing,
underneath goal,
I want you to write my responses. I'm
not talking about words. I'm talking
about your physical body responses.
What's going to be happening to you in
that moment? You need to know, do you
get tightness in your jaw? For me, it's
tightness in my shoulders right here.
The traps I get I get really tight when
I when I know I'm tense because I have
to like constantly relax them. It's my
body preparing. I have to constantly
react. I have to constantly relax them.
So, in my responses, say what's
happening to you. Jog, it's tight. Fist
clench.
Shoulders tense.
I had somebody who say, "My toes, my
toes like to uh scrunch up." If you need
if that's you, write that down, too. You
need to know what's happening. Why? So
that you will not be surprised when it's
happening. It's preparing for every part
of the conversation. Conversations are
not just words. They are the emotions
and the physical elements in the room.
All right? It is it is not just emotion.
is just as physical as can be because
they're going to read your body language
more than they're going to listen to
your words. So, when it comes to
preparing for this hard conversation,
focus on regulating your body first
before we start worrying about your
words. Cool. Number three, while we're
talking about words, if you're going to
rehearse anything, I want you to
rehearse your opening line. That's it.
Know your opening line. That's it.
Whenever you start to think of how it's
going to play out five minutes into the
conversation, there's no way it's going
to happen. If you can get out your
opening line really well, that's really
the only thing you can control at the
init at the start of the conversation.
Everything else is going to be what it's
going to be and it's all going to be on
you and your emotions. Now, I say start
with your opening line because that sets
the tone for the conversation. that in
to my in my opinion is absolutely worth
rehearsing that you feel really
comfortable with the first words that
come out of your mouth. I'd say that 98%
of the time the direction of the
conversation is set by the tone and in
the first words that you share. So if I
want to have a hard conversation with
you, I'm going to put a lot of emphasis
in my mind of remembering rehearsing my
the opening what I want to begin with.
So, I want you to write down underneath
my responses. My opening my opening.
Write down your opening sentence to this
person. Imagine yourself in the context
and get really comfortable with the
opening sentence. What I like to open
with, and I'm just going to I'm going to
throw out some responses that that might
feel natural to you. All right? Is
saying I'm going to share something
that's really important to me. I like to
to share something that's very important
to me. Something as simple as that.
If you want to add to it, I want to
share something that's really important
to me and
I know it's not going to be perfect.
Or you can even ask and is it okay with
you if I if I don't say everything
perfectly?
This is going to be a difficult
conversation, but I'm going to be right
here with you through the end.
This is a conversation that I know it's
not going to be resolved now
and I'm going to be in this conversation
over the next month for however long it
takes.
Sometimes put not putting a time frame
on conversation is very helpful instead
of saying we need to have a conversation
right now and expect a decision. This is
a conversation we're going to have over
the next week, over the next month,
whatever it is. When you release the
time, it's like the pressure valve goes
off. You're releasing the pressure, the
tense moment of it.
Find your opening line.
Maybe it's you needing to reveal some
stuff like, "I'm struggling with some
thoughts and I really want your help.
I'm stressed about this conversation
because it matters so much to me." I'd
encourage you to actually reveal a
little bit about what's happening
inside. Reveal the nerves. Reveal the
imperfect. Reveal the struggle. Believe
it or not, it's going to help them
relate to you more than you could ever
dream. If you sit with them and say,
"This is a conversation I've been
dreading to have,
and I hope that together
we can get through this in a way that's
going to make a big difference." This is
a conversation I've been dreading to
have, and I I really need your help.
There's something I I want to share with
you, and I I know I'm I'm not going to
get it down perfectly.
Are you willing to just be here with me?
Be willing to
reveal a little bit. Just I'm not saying
a lot, but if your opening line can be
just a little bit vulnerable with the
inner emotions,
what that's going to do is break so much
ice to actually be real to talk to one
another. All right. How do we prepare
for that difficult conversation, that
stressful conversation? Instead of that
knot in your stomach, we're going to
move some energy. You do that by writing
down what we just talked about. So,
number one, know your goal. Number two,
know your responses, your body, what's
happening. That way, you're not going to
get caught off by it in the moment. And
number three, rehearse your opening
line. Know your opening line because
that you can at least control. And
additional bonus, if you can reveal a
little bit of the struggle. What are you
struggling with yourself? Like if you
were just going to talk to me and say,
[snorts] um, you Jefferson, I want to
have this hard conversation and I'm
worried about it because I'm I'm I'm
afraid they're not going to I'm afraid
reveal that whatever that is. I'm afraid
that X maybe you need to write that
down, too. I'm afraid that
and use that fear and put it at the
beginning of the conversation. I need to
share something important with you and
I'm I'm afraid that if I do, this is
going to happen. You hear how all of a
sudden you've got that out in the open.
You're not you're not you're not
carrying that inside. It's not unspoken.
You've now said it and now they can
understand. Okay, this is this is
serious and now I'm going to have this
conversation with you.
All right,
I'm proud of you. I want to encourage
you that this is not everybody does
this. Let me tell you, nobody does it
super well. Even the conversations I
need to have. Yeah. Do I make mistakes?
Yeah, but that's what makes me human.
There's no such thing as a perfect
stressful, hard, difficult conversation
gone well. The best thing you can do is
find the reason within yourself. Why is
it difficult? When I say difficult
conversation, what makes it difficult?
Find that answer. Be more focused on
that answer. If you can just remove the
difficulty, then it's just a
conversation.
Then it's not a difficult one. It's just
a conversation. And sometimes what makes
it difficult is not the other person,
it's me. Do the homework, prepare for
it, plan for it, and you will not be
surprised. And when you eliminate the
surprises, you reduce the anxiety. And
all of a sudden, what you thought was so
difficult really just becomes another
conversation. All right, you got this.
If you can encourage I want to not only
encourage you, but whenever you do have
that conversation, will you email me? I
you can go um
hello@jffersonsonfisher.com.
I I would love to hear how that
conversation went and get any kind of
feedback because I just want to
encourage you and speak a lot of good
into your life. All right. I want to
talk to you a little bit about difficult
conversations because this everybody
has. I mean, I feel like in my work
life, I you know, I have to have
difficult conversations with people
pretty consistently. Where I would
struggle is having conversations with
people that I love. So, how do you even
approach having the really hard
conversations with someone? And is
there, you know, is there a very
different way that you think about the
really hard stuff like when it matters?
>> Yes, there is. First thing you want to
do is think of the end of it. Don't
start with the beginning. Start with the
end of it.
>> Like what is what's the outcome I want
to have?
>> What's the goal? What's the ultimate
ask? Too many people wait until they're
talking to figure out what they want to
say.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And that creates a big problem because
it it leads the other person guessing
and you're trying to land the plane and
they're trying to start butting in.
You're going, "No, no, no. That's not
it. Wait, wait, wait." And you don't
even know where you want to go. All
often we just don't know how we want to
land the plane. So number one, you want
to end when you want to begin with what
the outcome is going to be. So have that
in your mind before you even start the
conversation. What is the ultimate ask?
Don't be thinking of that smart little
comment, that little zinger you're going
to throw in. how you're really going to
while you're brushing your teeth. That's
a good point. I'm going to say this. You
want to focus on what's the ultimate ass
going into it. It's going to make it a
whole lot better for you.
>> Do you have an example of like a
difficult conversation you've had to
have and how you've handled it?
>> Yeah. I had to let somebody go. So, I've
>> It's always a nightmare to let someone
>> It's not Yeah. It's not It's not a good
feeling. No.
>> And there's some people though it's a
relief to let them go. I mean, because
you know it's your your team's going to
get better. The drama is going to be
reduced. you're you're going to you have
to prune the tree to make it grow. And
it's this um so this is what happened. I
I had to let somebody go in the law firm
where I see a lot of people mess up and
and firing someone is they begin with
the kindness and they'll say something
like so Emma, how how are you doing? Are
you good? How's your family? You're
good. Have you have you seen the the
weather outside? It's crazy, right?
Yeah, I know.
>> Uh so listen. [laughter] Uh and that's
right there. Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
>> The So listen. Oh, it it just they are
they're waiting for that hammer to drop.
So instead, what you want to do is lead
with the hard and it's it can sound just
like this. If you just let's say I need
to let you go, heaven forbid. And I sat
down and we sat down and I said, "Emma,
I got bad news." And you're going to
kind of and I give you a pause. Give you
four seconds, three seconds, and you're
going to kind of go, [sighs]
>> you're like, "All right, you allow the
ready yourself and then I'll say, I got
to let you go.
You've been wonderful. See, now I'm
leading with the compliments. You've
been wonderful part of the team. We've
really enjoyed having you. I look
forward to where your career is going to
go. It's just not going to be here. Like
anytime you lead with the small talk of
how's your family? How's it going?
>> So listen, uh they hold it against you
because it means everything that you
said before wasn't sincere.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Now they don't want to connect
with you because
>> totally
>> now you're inauthentic.
>> But when I can just say this is going to
be a difficult conversation. So, let's
say it's just an something sensitive,
something that you're in trouble and I
need to talk to you. This is going to be
a difficult conversation. This isn't
going to be a fun conversation. This is
going to be hard to talk about. This
might come as a shock to you. Anything
that I can do to just prep you, like on
my team, if they call first thing if
something's wrong, they say, "You're not
going to like this." That's the first
thing out of their mouth. I go, "Okay."
>> That's every call I get all day.
[laughter]
>> That's every call.
>> No one ever calls me with good news.
>> And what happens is we always think that
the the worst possible outcome.
>> Totally. So then it's often times not as
bad
>> and then and when they tell it you're
like, "Oh, that's that's it. I don't I
can deal with that.
>> Yeah, that's yeah, I can I can I can
deal with that."
>> It feels like preparedness has a lot to
do with it because you're very very
thoughtful with your words. Do you do
like do you think ahead of difficult
conversations or any conversations like
you ought to like have practiced first?
>> I don't find the practicing is helpful
uh because it means
>> how do you be so how do you be so
precise with the words though?
>> It's your body. Your body is what's
controlling it. The first rule would be
let your breath be the first word that
you say.
>> Oh, that's a great tip. Let your breath
be the first word. So, you're like take
a conscious breath.
>> Yes. And it's uh it uses it's called a
conversational breath and it uses the
advantages of what they call a
physiological sigh. So, we're going to
go in through our nose like three
seconds and one more at the top through
your nose. It's a double inhale then
relax.
>> What's the other person doing while
we're breathing like this? Well, it's
really quick. You're never going to
know. So, okay, fine. For example, I I
I've been doing it now and you just you
just never know. So, yeah. And so, you
do it you do it when somebody's saying
something that you don't like.
>> And what's that like? What is actually
happening during that conversational
breath?
>> So, it it's like a a sigh. Have you ever
been like,
>> and you're like, okay, now you can't do
that in regular conversation, but it's
the same effect. And what it's doing is
calming your nervous system.
>> It's like taking the temperature down.
>> Yeah. More importantly, what it's
telling your body is this does not
threaten me. So, whatever they tell me,
if it's something negative, if there is
something hectic and chaotic, then you
can use your breath before either you
say it or while somebody is talking, it
is just queuing you in to your body
saying, "This does not threaten me."
>> And whenever you do that, because a lot
of times we we hold our breath, Emma,
that's what we do.
>> I find myself doing that all the time.
>> It's it's really easy. Sometimes I feel
like I've done that for the full day.
>> Yeah.
>> Like you know what I mean? Like it's
just in there and I get like in the car
and I'm like
>> Exactly. Like unbelievable.
>> Or like really shallow breathing
>> or I hold my breath while I email, you
know? I'm like
>> Exactly. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. And what does it just it it
just tweaks you up. I mean that's why
sometimes we yell.
>> It's just expelling. Yeah. Yeah. Nobody
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> though, right? Of course it does.
>> It's like a ball inside. So you just
have to remember to breathe. Well,
there's a lot of things to keep in mind,
but breath is the first go-to because if
you have your breath in line, a lot of
things go well. So, if you were to say
something ugly to me, we can talk about
those concepts. It's
>> letting it drop, letting it have time,
>> the more time I can add distance for us
to let not just my body regulate, let
your body
>> Exactly. Because all of the sudden
you're like, you're in that situation
where now I've got to think about what I
just said. You took a breath, so now I'm
like, Yes.
>> Did I what actually did I just say?
>> It allows just for that moment your
analytical side, that logical side to
stay at the forefront rather than
getting wrapped up in the emotion of
trying to win and trying to prove you
wrong. I wanted to talk right away if
possible about uncomfortable or
difficult conversations because a large
part of my work is helping people not to
avoid those difficult conversations
because I never really like them and
I've never known how to have them. And
you shared something recently and I
thought I would like to dissect it a
little bit with you. Um
it was something it was how to have
difficult conversations and there were
three things that you said you said
don't start with small talk
always say you know I need your help and
with the wrapup you can say I feel more
settled or I feel like better about
where we're headed with this how do you
feel and when you said don't start with
small talk instead you said thank you
for taking the time to talk to me and
I love that because I think that with
the difficult conversations we tend to
get a little awkward and we tend there's
there's a couple of things that happen.
So, one is what I loved about your
advice is how to initiate the
conversation. And a lot of people,
especially in my world, when I'm helping
people with relationships, they start
with this phrase, we need to talk. And I
think that phrase is literally the thing
that makes the other person want to poop
their pants. [laughter]
Like in that moment is you and people
immediately go into the defensive. they
immediately get scared and I think that
it triggers in them an avoidance like
okay now I'm in trouble I want to get
away from this and so would you agree
that starting with we need to talk the
same as don't start with small talk like
hey how are you it's more like let's get
to the chase but do we we need to talk
is that a terrible way to start a
conversation I think that and
you know my therapist
Anytime you begin the conversation with
we need to talk or or worse you text
that and nobody likes to get that text
we need to talk because it's like
hanging a hammer uh over their head like
a dark cloud. It's it's the fear of the
unknown where that fight or flight
starts to kick in. It's the anxiety of
oh no. we automatically go to the worst
possible scenario that it could be. So
almost always when you somebody sends
you we need to talk you respond what's
wrong [laughter]
because it's that fear of the unknown of
going I don't know what's going to
what's going to happen next and it does
put people on their heels. It does get
them defensive in a way because they are
already ready to defend about whatever
threat is going to be coming their way.
So anytime you say we need to talk, it
automatically just submerses the
conversation underwater and you have to
wait for them to kind of catch their
breath and be okay and clear in their
mind before you can actually engage in
meaningful dialogue. I like to say don't
begin with the small talk because it's
often not very kind in a way. Whenever
you need to have a difficult
conversation with somebody, often you
don't want to go through the front door.
You like to kind of walk around to see
how it's going. You go, "Hey, how are
the kids? How's everybody going? How's
your how's your pickle ball game?" You
know, how's uh this weather's been
crazy, right? you. It's this feeling of
I need to have a little bit of distance
and fluff before we talk because you've
heard it. We You have this uh fluff of,
you know, wow, this weather's crazy,
right? Well, hey, uh listen uh we need
to That's the cue right there is the
listen. So, we need to actually what I
need to talk right there is the Okay,
what you've just told me is everything
you said before about asking about my
family. how's everybody doing? It didn't
mean a thing to you.
>> It wasn't sincere. It wasn't genuine.
Now, we're about to talk to really what
you want to talk about. And and the
worst part is during that fluff period,
you leave the other person kind of twist
in the wind. They're sitting in their
chair kind of moving back and forth
going, "No, I know what are they what do
you what am I doing here? I know you
need to talk to me." Their eyes are
shifting around. They get uncomfortable.
they get nervous because they can feel
that pressure of you're talking about
things that I know that's not why we're
here to talk. So often leading with
small talk can be a very insincere way
particularly with the difficult
conversations.
>> Yeah, I would agree. And I would
actually also say that when we say I,
you know, we need to talk, it's a power
move because a lot of people will say we
need to talk because they're pissed,
they're angry,
>> and they almost they want to control
their partner, let's just say, and they
actually want their partner to be
nervous.
Now, um, not everyone does it that way,
but I do find it to be quite
manipulative. I know I've done it in the
past where I've said, you know, we need
to talk. It's like, okay, we're serious
now. You need to pay attention to me.
And if you're in a relationship and
let's just say you don't feel very paid
attention to or
you feel like it's very difficult to get
the person's attention. It's almost like
a form of punishment. Like you said,
it's not very kind. And I think that
people do that as a way to kind of gain
control, but it's the worst. It's the
worst tactic. I mean, when you said, "I
need your help." I love that because
what you're then inviting the person
into is a conversation,
a collaboration,
a brainstorm session, as opposed to let
me just go down a list of all the things
that I'm angry at you about or all the
things that you're doing wrong and call
this a difficult conversation. when
really it's not a conversation at all.
It's attack and the other person goes on
defend. So, um yeah. Anything you want
to add to that?
>> When you begin with the we need the
person here,
>> do we? Is that what we need or is that
is that what you need? Yeah. It's
>> it it can be a power move.
>> Most of it it all goes back to the
intent. I don't I don't believe most
people use it manipulative. they just
don't know what else to say. They know
that there needs to be a conversation.
They just don't know how to engage it.
So, they think by using the word we,
>> it's going to make it feel more
together. And often that is the case.
But this is kind of a weird exception.
And when you begin with we need to talk,
they have no context. I mean, if my my
wife texts me that, I feel like I have
done something terribly wrong.
>> Yeah. You're in trouble. You feel like
you're in trouble.
>> Exactly. And so it just it doesn't lead
that way where if if somebody were to
text me, hey, I need to speak with you.
Do you have any time X, Y, and Z? Or
just giving them a preview of what you
need to talk about? I need to talk to
you about the budget decisions for
tomorrow. Do you have any space to talk
between X, you know, X, Y, and Z? That
at least gives a little bit of preview.
But it can often be a form I don't think
of intentional punishment but that is
certainly the consequence of it.
>> Yeah. Okay. And then
wrapping it up. I feel more settled. How
do you feel? I think that that touching
base just to see how the other person
feels is very important. I also think so
this can be with anyone in your life.
>> This can be a work person. This can be a
a romantic partner. This could be a
friend. Um,
how do you feel? So then the other
person matters, right? It's often when
we have those difficult, tense
conversations,
we can end them very abruptly,
unintentionally if I just say, "Okay,
well, I feel better now. All right,
thank you." You know, you get up from
the room and you go about your day. you
kind of leave the other person hanging
like, "Well, I I don't feel better about
it. I'm glad you do. I'm glad you got
what you needed and you took it."
>> Yeah.
>> But you can't you can't um kick down a
sand castle and then expect the other
person not to be somewhat upset about it
uh or feel differently about it. So,
it's always a good idea to ask, you
know, I feel I feel a little bit more
settled now. I feel better now that we
spoke. How are you feeling? just to
check in with them just a little bit.
Even if they tell you a lie, even even
if they say, "I'm good." When they're
not, you can't control that. But you at
least provided the opportunity for them
to say, "Ah, I still kind of feel I
still feel unsettled." You go, "Okay,
let's then let's keep talking. I got 5
minutes. I got 10 minutes. Let's let's
keep talking. I want to make sure." And
that way can they can bring up anything
else rather than them feeling like they
just got drugged along and somewhat in
the dirt for you to ask and poke every
little question and they're still left
unresolved. So it's just something that
they can
>> you can kind of meet in the mind a
little bit.
>> But there is
an art to communicating. There is an art
to arguing. There is an art which I
think has become the phenomenon of you
and and what you're speaking about and
you have a threepart framework. Right.
>> Say it with control,
>> say it with confidence, say it to
connect.
>> That's right.
>> And why is that order so important?
That order is important because it
begins with what you can control first
and that is yourself.
>> So often in conversation, the first
thing we want to do is control them.
We're looking for what can control you.
Now, you're not saying what I want you
to say. You're not responding how I want
you to respond. No, what you should say
is X, Y, and Z. And when you set out
that way to control the other person,
you're losing the most important moment
and [clears throat] regaining your
composure in conversation and that is
controlling yourself. So that's why rule
number one is all about controlling
yourself. Two goes into the confidence
meaning that you can't get it across
unless you have the assertive voice to
say what you need to say to be confident
in it. And then when it comes to the
difficult conversations, rule number
three is you're saying it to connect,
meaning you're having understanding,
you're having acknowledgement, and
that's going to build connection and
build a better relationship. But that's
it's a framework that if the
conversation's not going well, most
likely one of those three are are
missing. Maybe you're not saying it with
control because you're yelling, or maybe
you're not saying it to connect because
you're caring more about what you're
what you're saying. Yeah,
>> I yell, Jefferson. I don't mean to yell,
but I then I get all
>> You don't realize you're yelling. In
your defense, you don't realize you're
yelling.
>> I get all fiery.
>> Nothing wrong with that.
>> I mean,
>> it's natural. That's the point. It's
natural.
>> You know what it is? I get invested,
right? I get invested in people or I get
invested in things like I I really put
my heart, my soul, like I get invested
and then I just like lose all my
boundaries. Like I lo I lo like say it
with control. I never say it with
control. I never say, do I ever say it
with control my teams over there? I
don't. I just I don't. They work for me.
But
>> would you would people say you're
passionate? Is that what you would call
it?
>> What? Rosie Canon, would you say I'm
passionate? I'm very passionate. I'm
very like, but I'm passionate about
everything,
>> right? Like I'm a passionate person.
Like I'm not
>> I don't know what you're passionate too,
but you're in a different She's much
calmer.
>> Got it. That would mean you're you're
dynamic in conversation, meaning your
highs are really high and your lows are
really low. There's typically no there's
typically no middle.
>> Yeah. I don't really have gray. I don't
have a middle. Like
>> Yeah. But then I'm trying cuz I started
a company. So, I'm really like I'm
trying and like I had to fire someone
the other day and normally I'm the one
who does it with, you know, HR or
somebody because I feel bad or I feel
guilty or and it was the first time
where I couldn't do it cuz I was so
upset about having to do it. Like I
literally couldn't do it.
>> Mhm.
>> And so I took myself out of it, which I
never do.
>> And I ended up speaking to the person
like four days later and it was the best
thing I ever did. M there's nothing
wrong with taking time. I think there is
this stigma that when you're in
conversation, you have to have this
immediate response. Just because they
said something or just because they have
an opinion, then you are automatically
required to also have an opinion. And in
fact, you have to share that opinion
right now. I think I think when you're
on the receiving end too, it's sort of I
I listened to a podcast episode with Mel
Robbins and you were on it and sometimes
it's like you realize that when people
are arguing with you or if you're having
an argument with your husband or
whatever
>> a lot of the times it actually has
nothing to do with the recipient, right?
Like it doesn't have anything to do with
me. And I think that what what this
episode you guys were talking about was,
you know, goes back to the whole let
them theory that Mel has, but you have
to sort of I think it's one thing to
know how to argue and and have all of
that, but it's another
there's another side of it, which is to
know how to receive the argument,
>> right?
>> And I think that's equally important,
right? Because your reaction can then
trigger something further. So, it's kind
of like sparring a little bit and
knowing in both ways what your defense
should be to an offense, right?
>> Yeah. And we uh have the tendency to
take things as a challenge.
>> Any little thing. Maybe it's an opinion
you don't like
>> or maybe you see something differently
than the other person. You want them to
accept your way of seeing it totally
rather than theirs.
>> Which is winning. Exactly. Which is
winning. Because a lot of us were raised
to think that winning the argument was
the goal, right?
>> Oh, yeah. There's still books and blogs
and
>> how do you say the opposite though? What
is the real mind? What the the mindset
that can be dangerous is that?
>> Yeah.
>> So, what do we aim for?
>> Instead of seeing arguments as something
to win, I want you to see them as
something to unravel.
>> Meaning you you think of them as a as a
knot. So, anytime, let's say there's a
straight line between me and you,
something's going to happen or there's a
snag, like there's um I'm taking
something the wrong way. There's some
kind of miscommunication and a knot
starts to form.
>> What we want to do typically is say,
"No, you see it my way." And then you
go, "No, see it my way." And what it
does is just make that knot harder and
harder to undo. Do you have some
heruristics or or methods of
approaching those difficult
conversations where a guy needs to have
that conversation? You know, you hear
things like, you know, bring up the
positive first and then like [laughter]
throw it down easy. I mean, you hear
these types of things, but
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I've always thought the sandwich
didn't taste very good. I I I like to
communicate things in terms of a frame
and this is probably one of the most
powerful tools you can have when it
comes to having a difficult conversation
and that is you tell them what you want
to talk about. You tell them how you
want it to end and then you you get your
buy in into it. So, let's say Ryan,
you and I are working on a team. I have
some kind of a little bit more
supervisory role in this and I need to
address something serious with you. I
could come to you and say, "Ryan, I need
to talk about the comments you made at
last Thursday's meeting." And at the end
of this conversation, I need to know
that's not going to happen again. Sound
good? You're going to go, "Sounds good."
And then we get to actually talk about
it. Now, I got your buy in. Now you're
now in a weird way it's like a verbal
contract to where you feel like you're
we don't have to worry about any other
issue. We know that this is solely the
frame. This is what we're going to talk
about. Now you compare that with what I
just like to call a a very upfront
sentence meaning any difficult
conversation you need to have and you're
going to I use these all the time. You
just tell them you label the
conversation itself. So, I might start
with, "Ryan, this is going to be a
difficult conversation." As easy as
that. This isn't going to be fun to talk
about. This may come as a shock to you.
This is going to be hard for us to
discuss. Whenever you say those things
and kind of give them a little bit of a
pause, they kind of gather themselves up
and ready themselves rather than this
wandering. Hey, so you know how you
we've been dating for like, you know, 6
months and it's been great. Really, it
has. And all of a sudden, they're just
like, they start losing their mind. They
start spinning in circles. You're not
going fast enough, but you're trying to
be kind. You're trying to let them down
easy. Uh, no. It's it's a terrible
painful thing for them to go through.
Instead, you just need to be very
upfront right out of the gate. This
isn't going to be fun for us to talk
about or you're not going to like this
or this is going to be hard to discuss.
That's going to go way better than
trying to him and haul as they say.
Yeah, I think that's a really good point
because I think when you do what you
called the sandwich thing where it's
compliment, critique, compliment type
framework, it really all you're doing
and people aren't dumb.
>> No,
>> you're just teeing people up, you know?
So, it's like if you if you came to me
and said,
>> "Hey, Ryan, look, I wanted to talk with
you. Um, you know, I I think you're a
great podcast." And I'm like, "Oh,
cool." You know, and I'm all excited and
you're like, "But I don't want to be on
>> for the hammer. You got it."
>> Dude, I already knew that was coming. So
why don't you just leave with that and
not waste anybody's time?
>> Exactly. Or um you know part of that
advice is not to start with the small
talk. Don't sm start with the
pleasantries of when you sit down and
somebody goes so how are things? You're
good. Everybody kids are good. People
are healthy. Man, this weather it's
crazy, right?
>> Yeah. What's what are we doing here?
>> And then here's here's what they say.
They'll say, "Oh, this weather's crazy."
Right? So listen, uh, you know how like
just that right there, the so listen,
it's a little bit more of a tone. And
what it's communicating is everything I
just asked about, it was just fluff. It
doesn't really mean anything. I I just
didn't want to get right into the
conversation, what we needed to discuss.
But everybody knows, I mean, everybody
has this six sense of that's not why you
called me in here. So anytime it's a
start with a high positive, people are
thinking, what's wrong? the entire time.
>> Yeah.
>> When's it coming?
>> It to me Yeah. To me when you say that
and as we talk about this, it just seems
like
>> it's just more respectful. You know,
sometimes we'll say, and I've caught
myself doing this where I'll say, "Well,
I care so much about this person. I
don't want to hurt them."
>> If I'm being honest though, when I'm
doing it that way, the improper way I
would say, is I'm not so much concerned
with their feelings as much as I'm
concerned about how I feel about their
feelings. So it's more about me than it
is about them.
>> Oh man, that's such a good point. Yes.
So anytime you are afraid to be direct
with that person to deliver that bad
news, what you're really saying is that
you don't believe they have enough
emotional resiliency where they they
have to rely upon you and your
communication skills to gently put them
on a cloud and make them feel better
somehow after the conversation. when
it's much more when you're direct, it's
could be much more kind in a way. It's
much more respectful to just say what
you need to say right out of the gate
rather than try to come at it
indirectly.
Today we're talking about how to have a
difficult conversation. What is it about
difficult conversations that well make
them so difficult and how can you make
them a little easier in your life? When
it's time for that difficult
conversation, number one, don't begin
with, "How are you?" How are things?
Difficult conversations are not the time
for small talk. The only thing that
should come out of your mouth is, "Thank
you for making the time to talk with
me." Number two, follow that up with, "I
need your help. I need your help knowing
how to feel about this. I need your help
knowing what to do about this." When you
say, "I need your help," it takes it
from opponents to teammates. And number
three, end with how you feel about the
conversation. I feel better having
talked with you. I feel more settled
after discussing this. And the key is
you then end it with so how about you?
When you say how about you, you are
getting them to connect with you to say
how do you feel about this conversation?
Do you feel better about it or do we
need to continue to talk? Now when I get
questions about how to have a difficult
conversation, it typically revolves
around having to deliver bad news.
Meaning there is something negative that
you need to say to someone and you know
they are not going to like it. You know
they're going to get upset. It's going
to bother them. It's going to ruin the
mood. It's going to ruin the the
atmosphere or or possibly ruin the
relationship. Or you see it with how to
address a sensitive topic. Maybe it's
something that's been laid heavy on your
heart and you don't know how to start or
something that's been bothering you and
you know it's for the best that you talk
to this other person about it and you
just don't know where to begin. You
remove the difficult from difficult
conversations when you break it down
into bite-sized pieces that are going to
connect you to that other person. Now
typically in my life where I see
difficult conversations is when I have
to deliver bad news to a client. You
know not every case is perfect and not
every client is a good client and not
every case is a good case. The law
applies to the facts. So sometimes you
have to tell them I'm sorry but the law
doesn't allow this or the law is against
you on this case. So that just is part
of normal life. And how you handle that
conversation, meaning not just what you
say, but more importantly, how you say
it, can mean the difference between
making what comes after the difficult
conversation easier or just more
difficult. Now, the strategy does change
slightly depending on whether you need
to deliver bad news or simply discuss a
sensitive topic. When it comes to
strictly bad news, the faster you get
that bad news out, the better the
conversation is going to go. For
example, if you have to fire someone,
the first thing out of your mouth should
be, "I have bad news." Or you need to
say something that's hard for them to
hear, you tell them that this is going
to be hard to hear. This is going to be
a difficult conversation. This is not
going to be fun for us to talk about.
You give them a pause and then you
deliver the bad news. In that moment,
directness is also kindness. All right?
And when it comes to sensitive topics,
it's much easier to follow steps one,
two, and three, where you're going to
say, "Thank you for talking with me. Um,
I need your help. I feel better about
this." So, let's go through a everyday
typical conversation where you need to
say something that's hard for them to
hear. So, let's assume you need to have
a difficult conversation with someone
and let's make it about something they
said, a comment they made at a dinner
with friends last week. You've tried to
let it go, but it's just not happening
and you know that you need to talk with
them about it. If you're following rule
number one, what you're not going to do
is begin with, "So, how was this work?
How was this work today?" When you know
good and well, that's not at all what
you really care about. Because what's
worse is when you make them talk about
work and then you just drop the hammer
and say, "Oh, that's nice. Listen, you
remember what you said last week."
That's a safe way to set this up for
failure. Instead, what you're going to
do is set aside time and say, "Hey, when
you have a moment, can we talk about
something?" Next, you're going to go to
rule number two. I need your help. I
need your help knowing how to feel about
a comment you made at dinner last week.
I've tried to let it go. I have dealt
with it and and just kind of simmered on
it in my mind and I need your help with
it. Then have that conversation. Tell
them what they said. Tell them how it
made you feel. And that's the difficult
part is that you have to express your
own thoughts. And nobody can do that for
you. But what makes it easier is when
you lead with I need your help. People
love to be helpful. They want to be
helpful. rather than coming in and
making them defensive and and going into
attack mode. When you can say, "I need
your help." It doesn't feel like you're
sitting on two separate sides of the
table, right? It makes you feel like
you've instead scooted up a chair beside
you and said, "Let's sit together and
look at this problem that's on the table
in front of us and let's work through it
together." And when you're able to have
that conversation and say what you need
to say and get it all out or maybe you
just need to hear their perspective of
what they meant by their comment last
week, it's going to make it better and
bring you closer together because it's
the difficult conversations that allow
you the chance to dive deeper into your
relationship and grow and build. And
then after you've had that conversation,
number three, you're going to end with I
feel X. I feel better. I feel relieved.
I feel more settled. I feel better
knowing your perspective or where you
are coming from in it. And then you ask,
"How about you?" or "How are you
feeling? What do you think?" Get that
connection just a little bit closer to
to to wrap it up in a bow and say, "Hey,
we just went through something that that
was a little difficult. We went through
something that was not easy and let's
walk out of it handinand. Let's walk out
of it together." Whatever it is, you
have that meeting of the mind to say, "I
feel okay about this. You feel okay
about this? Got it. Good.
>> I want to kind of end on two things
here. Um, you me you started to mention
it. Let's say that you are about to have
a really difficult conversation. What
are some of the things you absolutely
should not do that most people do when
they're going to have one?
>> Begin with the fluff.
>> This uh compliment sandwich, what do
they call that?
>> Yeah. It's uh the compliment sandwich is
a little hard to chew and almost
impossible to swallow. It's this idea of
when you give the hey look, we've really
enjoyed your time here. We think you're
just I think you're such an awesome
person and you're so great, Cody. Uh so
listen, um and then they deliver the the
bad news. Well, that just means whatever
they said before
wasn't true. They said the word but
meaning everything that came out of it
didn't mean anything. It's like saying I
love you but that's got to go. Like
everything it doesn't matter what they
said before it it's always the end. And
so what you do is you leave them to kind
of just twist in the wind and it it's
not nearly as genuine.
>> So instead what you have to do is lead
with the difficult.
>> Trust me it will make it easier. It only
gets harder if you start with the easy
and gradually progress to the bad news.
>> When somebody says something like, "This
is going to be hard to hear." If I
versus me saying, "Hey, Cody, um, uh,
listen, you know how it's been really
hard here lately, and you know, we've it
look this economy, you know, and the
economy like whatever it is, you're just
you keep on going versus me saying,
"Cody, this is going to be hard to hear.
Cody, this is gonna be hard for us to
talk about. This isn't going to be fun.
You're not going to like this. Or just
as simple as this is going to be a
difficult conversation. All of a sudden,
Cody's gonna ready herself and go, okay,
it's kind of this, all right, lay it on
me. Everybody who you could possibly say
that to has that same power.
>> When you try and babyfoot it around and
start with the icing,
you're being disingenuous. And what
you're saying is you're not emotionally
resilient enough to handle it.
>> Um, I'm too afraid to disappoint you
because I want you to still like me.
>> But in truth, the kinder thing is to
say, I'm telling you this way because I
like you. Or even if you prime the
conversation of, Cody, I'm telling you
this because you can take it.
I'm telling you this bad news because I
like you and I have to I have to give it
to you. Then you give the bad news.
That's going to be a whole lot better to
start your difficult conversation every
single time. Whether it's a sensitive
conversation, whether it's you need to
fire somebody, whether it's you need to
talk about a difficult subject, you
label that conversation to let them know
rather than them having to try and
figure it out of like what's they're
waiting for that hammer to drop.
>> Yeah. You know what else is fascinating
is every time you do that, you want to
nod back. Like if you say, "Cody, this
is going to be a difficult
conversation." My initial reaction is
like, "Okay." Yep. Yep. Yes, it will be
like it feels like truth. You've already
got me having confirmation.
>> Yep.
>> Verbally or or physically. So, it's
interesting.
>> And you always think the worst.
>> Yeah.
>> If I were to say,
>> "Cody, I got bad news."
>> You're going to think somebody died or
you might be thinking you're getting
fired or you might be thinking, "What?"
You're going to think the very bottom of
it. And if it is the bottom, then you
expected it.
>> Yeah.
>> And if it's not, most of the time it's
not as bad as you think. You go, "Oh,
okay. Oh, that's it. Okay, I can handle
that. Like, it's this reverse psychology
of you. Uh, I can handle that. That's
not nearly as bad as I thought it was
going to be.
>> Jefferson, you talk the most about
interpersonal relationships
>> and not maybe as much about
relationships.
>> Yeah.
>> But if there's a young man or woman out
there wanting to have better
conversations with the opposite sex,
what is the most applicable advice you
have for communications from all the
things that you talk about?
>> Oh, that's not easy. I know
>> for when it comes to real relationships
that you're wanting to build, one is
transparency.
>> Like the number one killer is the
assumed or unspoken expectations.
>> Let's put it in in everyday life. Most
of the time we text, right? That's
that's how we communicate.
When you read into somebody's text and
the voice that you hear it in and you
expect it to be ugly or not nice and
it's a fine, oh okay, oh yeah, fine. All
right, good night. Like it's one of
those as simple as uh oh okay, I guess
they hate me. As soon as you get to that
point in your life
or anytime in that conversation, you are
are already setting yourself up for
failure in communication in the long
run. M
>> you have to voice what those
expectations are. So even if you were to
let's say text that if you can quickly
text back, did you mean for that to be
short or did you mean for that to sound
upset? And they go, "No, no, no, no. I
was just in the middle of X, Y, and Z."
Or, "Well, I just didn't like that you
said this." Oh, okay. And let's address
it. It's this goes back to this fear of
wanting to say the the hard thing
instead just complaining about it and
then later calling them a narcissist.
>> Yeah, exactly. [laughter] It doesn't
work out well, but it's all over the
internet. So, what's better to say, did
you mean Jefferson to say to sound upset
or did you mean Jefferson to be short or
to say I took it as short? Like, no. It
should always be on them. It
>> that did Did you mean for that?
>> For that.
>> I'm not saying you.
>> Yeah. So, don't put their name in there.
>> Don't Don't personalize it.
>> Good one.
>> Detach it. Detach the personalization.
So, that way it's not feeling like it's
a you
>> and you don't want to take it on
yourself because that sounds a little
too
I don't know what to say. I I feel like
you are being short. That would not
sound as smooth.
>> That wouldn't be dismissive. that might
be too much. There's nothing wrong with
that. I mean, that's perfectly fine.
>> But the did you mean is giving them the
grace of the fact that they did not
>> without internalizing it.
>> Uhhuh. And so it's not even you.
>> It doesn't get to the point of me
feeling like that. It's just simply uh
hey, I'm giving you a quick mirror here.
Did you mean for that to sound upset?
Did you mean for that to sound
>> rude? or between me and my wife, it's
Did you mean for that to sound short?
>> Mhm.
>> Because we're on the go and we're doing
things and sometimes it's like, "Oh,
okay. Well, I guess she's mad."
>> Uh, but it's no, it's just I'm dropping
off the the kids. I'm running this
errand. I'm on the phone. I'm on the
phone with the client. I'm texting you
while I'm on the phone. Right.
>> And so, a lot of the times it's just the
did you mean because most of the time
they did not mean.
>> It's wild though how those few words me
change so much.
>> They change everything. I know. So, you
really got to pay attention. You got to
read the book. You got to read it twice.
Um, [laughter] it's an incredible uh
book. I think you've already sold
hundreds of thousands of copies. You
have people over the world learning how
to communicate with a little bit more
kindness on both sides. And it's not
manipulative, which I really love. We're
not in the era of some guys that are,
you know, that I knew historically who
taught about seduction and
communication. This seems to be in a
very wholesome way. Might be your
Bowmont roots.
>> That's probably You're probably right.
You think so?
>> Probably right. Well, thank you,
[laughter] Cody.
>> Um, if you had to leave people with one
thought, like your favorite part of the
book that you want them to take with
them today, what would it be?
>> Have something to learn, not [snorts]
something to prove. Whenever you're in a
conversation with your friend, with a
spouse, [snorts] significant other,
anytime at work, living room, the
boardroom, have something to learn, not
something to prove. When you set out to
prove them wrong, you will most likely
get less in return. But when you set out
to ask the question internally of where
is this coming from? What do I have to
learn here? Your conversation's always
going to go a lot better and you're
going to have a better communication and
a better relationship. And that means a
better life.
>> So good. I actually uh always watch out
for the guys with the slow southern
draws because the people who have done
the best deals against me who have just
beat me up more than anything have been
smooth talking Texans.
>> Oh, you got to watch out for those.
>> You got to watch out. I remember up to
no good.
>> They're up to no good. Well, they're al
they always uh one of my favorite guys
in the world. He's incredible dealmaker.
I won't say his name because he'll get
embarrassed, but he's got a real slow
southern draw and he'll always say,
"Well, you know, for a kid from I won't
say I'm just a I'm just a guy from Texas
and I don't really understand that.
Could you explain it to me?" And then
I'll explain it to him and then he'll
proceed to just shred me.
>> That's how That's how you know. That's
how you know he knows.
>> That's how you That's the giveaway.
>> That's the dead giveaway that he already
understands it. He's already
>> I'm just kind of slow. I Can you explain
that to me again? I'm like, "Oh,
Here he comes." My favorite is to use is
maybe so like somebody says something no
matter if it's an idea or it could be
something mean or condescending or
typically it's some kind of idea I'll go
well maybe so like that right there to
me is it's my favorite power move to to
do because there's not there's nothing
you can do with it
>> and uh what happens is the other person
will actually start talking and like
saying my point for me in many ways but
yeah you just kind of slowly go Huh?
Maybe. So,
>> it's also the Well, that's a good dear
friend of mine, Joe from Kentucky.
That's what he does. He goes, "Well,
>> he just kind of leaves it." Well,
>> it's a great attitude to have.
>> It really is. It goes back to just being
in the pocket of I'm not really going to
be upset about this. Well, maybe it is,
maybe it isn't. I I don't know. One of
my most favorite videos that you do, and
I watch them all, but one of my most
favorite videos is when you were talking
about the fact that you can say a lot by
saying less.
>> And I want to just start there. What is
the benefit of saying less? I mean, you
you talk about communication. So, I'm
thinking lots of words and we need a lot
of words in these conversations, but the
fact that you could say a lot by saying
less, I'm intrigued. So, what's the
benefit? Why does it work?
Well, it starts with the premise that
the more you say, the less you mean. For
example, if if I you ask me to tell you
the truth about something or I'm
explaining my knowledge about something,
the more I have to say about it, uh it
usually suggests the less I know, you're
just talking to talk. So, if I'm going
to tell you the truth, you I need you
tell me the truth and I have to like,
okay, I need to explain this whole
story, the more it sounds like a lie. So
often you have to be extremely succinct
when it comes to communicating. It also
benefits you and that it keeps people
from misunderstanding you. It gives them
less to come back with. The shorter your
words, the more power and control that
you're always going to hold because they
don't have anything to grab on to and
misconstrue. So you might experience it
with maybe somebody in the audience has
texted that long paragraph to somebody
in an argument. They're very upset about
it. you send it, you're like, "Oh, I
just sent them this is the best 18
sentences I've ever sent to somebody."
And then they find out that the person
who responds, they only responded to one
maybe part of your sentence right in the
middle and ignored everything else. You
know, it's because you were not concise
enough to where they were able to
deflect and go to different issues. So,
usually the shorter the words, the more
powerful the message.
>> Okay, we're probably going to have to
come back to that one. so valuable for I
think every listener right now, but some
of my listeners, Jefferson, they don't
know you yet. And so, trial lawyer, you
own a law firm. Now, you're one of the
biggest voices in communication. So, you
got to take us back. How the heck did
this even start?
>> Yeah, nobody's more surprised than me.
Uh I this this started a little over two
years ago when I left a big defense
firm, big litigation firm as a partner
there and decided I wanted to I wanted
to have my own firm. I want to build my
own thing. And I mean you get that. And
so when I left on my own, I I didn't
have an office. I only had my laptop and
I went from coffee shop to coffee shop.
Well, now we have two locations and a
wonderful law firm, but at the time I
didn't really have anything. And so I
started to go, well, I feel like we're
youngish. I need to be on social media.
So, I started talking about my law firm.
And that just didn't feel good. So, I
then thought, what's one thing that I
can share that I feel like I know more
than anybody in my world and that gives
real value for people? Like, what's I
had this moment of what's my purpose?
Why why am I here? What am I leaving for
my kids? Do they want to look at my
social media and see I only talked about
me being an attorney? And so I sucked it
up and said, "Well, I don't have the
best lighting, the best camera. I didn't
have any of what I'm in right now." And
I'm just going to sit in my truck and
get my phone out and tell people how to
communicate. So I started with how to
argue like a lawyer, part one. And sure
enough, without me even thinking, it
started to grow. I went from like barely
800 followers, which are all friends, by
the way, which that was even more
intimidating when it's people you know
who you're like, "Oh, they're going to
hate me." And it just started to to grow
in there. And I got more questions and
more people asking how I can help. And I
I make almost daily content from my car
on how to communicate so that I can help
their next conversation.
>> Okay. So, what's fun about being friends
with Jefferson? Like, we're real friends
in real life. And I sat next to him for
two days at a mastermind. And so I
learned a lot about him. Like I hope
you're okay with me saying this, but do
not call Jefferson Jeff. Like don't do
it.
>> So there was this woman on stage,
wonderful woman, and she was presenting
and she kept saying Jeff because she was
using Jefferson as an example. I
literally felt your heat coming off your
body like that is not your name.
>> Yeah. My mom was always, if I wanted to
name you Jeff, I would have named you
Jeff. And
>> Jefferson is special. I like that. So,
>> yeah. I mean, in when I was in second
grade, we had this um where you'd have a
contest for who could write their name
the fastest. Like, I never won. Um it
was always a very long name to write,
but as I grew older, I I I loved it. I
don't know how I could ever be anything
else. And I'm certainly, for goodness
sake, I'm no Jeff. I can tell you that.
[laughter]
>> So, you all meet him when he's signing
books out in the world because he's
going to be everywhere. you just make
sure you call him Jefferson. That is
very, very important there. But I was
going to say what's fun about being your
friend is that I watch your videos and I
remember just recently I wanted to know,
do you record those in real time?
Because you were talking about something
about being impatient and you know me, I
like to know it all. So I sent him a
text and I'm like, are are you recording
these on the same day? And you said yes.
And then I told him like, why are you
impatient? What's going on over there?
Tell me everything. The fact that you do
it in the same day is pretty cool. Do
you feel stressed with that? And the
reason I ask is the women that are
listening, men and women that are
listening, they're growing their social
media, they're growing their online
businesses. So, before we get into more
communication, which I can't wait, this
consistency, how did you stay
consistent? Also, it doesn't take you
just two minutes, right? Are we doing
extra takes? I know you're not really
editing. Can you kind of talk how you
got into that habit?
So, I grew from less than 800 followers
to over 10 million followers doing the
exact same thing that I do. And anybody
listening, anybody tuning in can do the
exact same thing. I just get my phone, I
sit in my car, and I as I leave the
office, I think, what do I want to share
with them? What's something that
happened in my day? What's something
that maybe somebody in a comment has
asked? I'm like, that's a good question.
And I then think of it. I break it up
into three steps. Anybody can do this
the one two three it's easy I would
encourage you to try it and then you can
feel out if that's the format for you or
not but you always want to have this is
what I've learned mind you what I am
saying right now are things that I have
learned I had I googled how to make a
real I googled why do my videos have
zero views all right so don't you
thinking like I already had this
knowledge beforehand at zero what you
want to do is make sure at the very
outset you have a very clear title of
exactly what you're going to give them
what's the value and then I break it
into one through three and then I have a
call of action which was try that and
follow me that started for me googling
what's a good call to action and that's
how that happened I make my videos that
day because
I am not very good apparently at
batching anything
>> it's a big topic Jefferson we talk about
batching a lot over here
>> yeah um now I know that here's the thing
the smart people batch you batch. People
that are better than me batch. I have
not had the bandwidth to go, okay, I'm
going to set aside a whole day or half a
day for me to just go, okay, what's a
good question and make these videos. I
don't I don't don't have a video team.
Nobody's filming me. It is just me in my
car. But that's part of the
authenticity. You don't have to have uh
somebody come in a videographer and have
something uh choreographed with trendy
music. You don't you don't have to do
that. It is the value that you're giving
them right in that moment because they
want that realness. They they like that.
Uh so don't feel like you have to polish
because I think it honestly works
against you sometimes if it's if it's
too polished. It can be a turnoff. I it
takes me about from beginning to end
about 45 minutes sometimes an hour it in
the longest it it's gotten shorter
because finally Instagram I make my
videos all within Instagram right within
the app no I don't use some cap cut
different app it's all within Instagram
and
they Instagram finally fixed their
captions because their captions were
terrible and I'd have to like go in and
edit words and it just never looked
good. I was not happy with it. It had
this like black box that would like
flip. Well, now they have it to where it
would it kind of goes along as you talk.
I'm like, that's much better. So,
usually the hardest part was just the
captions. I do have different takes and
it's just a process of me doing it in
that moment. So, I might like how I said
something and go, "Oh, I I I like how I
just said that." I might ramble even for
the first a minute of talking out loud
in my car of okay, I'm thinking of one
person. That's important for anybody
listening. Think of one person. Don't
think of all the other people you're
posting to. Just think of one because
that's really the only facetime you're
going to have. Somebody who's going to
engage with your content. You're talking
to just one person, not a crowd. And
when that happens, I like to shorten
everything. So, you don't want to have
very long sentences. You want to shorten
it. And every second is precious. So, I
will retweak my title instead of how to
handle difficult people. I might even uh
shorten that even or people make this
mistake a lot. And I know you see this
Amy is when somebody says they begin
their video with, "I get this question
all the time. How do you do X, Y, and
Z?" And it's like, first of all,
nobody's asked you that most likely. Uh
you're just wanting to sound like that.
Second of all, you've wasted seven
seconds ex trying. It's really because
you feel self-conscious that you you're
not good enough on your own to just
share this advice. You need to make them
feel like you're an expert and that you
uh you have enough worth to now I can
share it and I have credibility because
I told you other people have asked me
for it. So, I just eliminate that.
They're going to see that and feel that
based on how you communicate.
I love that you shared that because I
think people would be surprised to know
you don't batch that you do it the same
day and you think about it when you're
driving home. Like I love that you have
made it so simple and so easy in terms
of someone else adopting that strategy.
So I wanted you to share that because I
thought that was fascinating.
>> Well, thank you. Yeah. And the only
other thing I'd add is that if you do
bash, it's not a problem. I want you
feeling like there's something wrong
with that. It's I just haven't been able
to work that in my life. And on the flip
side of it is if I'm not able to get a
video out that day, I just don't get a
video video out that day. Like the
people that are going to follow you will
follow you and the ones that are
unfollow you, so so what? It's it's it's
just the people that want to support you
will be there. So don't feel like
because you back something is wrong.
That's just what works for my life. So
the message is do what's easiest and
best for you and your world.
>> Yes. But just do it. Your consistency is
admirable. So, I feel like that has been
part of your success, the fact that we
know you're always showing up for us.
So, that's a big deal.
>> If you enjoyed that clip and want to see
the rest of the conversation, you can
click right here. Or if you want to see
the latest episode of the Jefferson
Fisher podcast, click right here and
I'll meet you